bienvenue dans le bureau de david jobin
compagnon depuis deux ans à la
communauté d'emmaüs loire et son rôle
depuis 48 heures c'est de sélectionner
et mettre en vente des objets sur le
site internet de l'association label
emmaüs on a fait déjà six ventes et je
pensais que ce serait un peu compliqué
au début mais en fait on crée des
comptes pour les envois postaux et puis
tout se fait par internet on nous sort
le coupon on a juste à empaqueter en
carton bien protéger les objets bien
emballé coller l'étiquette dessus et
déposés en point relais livrés à
domicile donc pouvoir retirer
directement sur place
les internautes ont le choix ici le but
est de vendre les objets qui n'ont pas
trouvé de repreneur dans les locaux
emmaüs espère toucher des jeunes plus
souvent branchés sur internet et même
des collectionneurs à la recherche
d'objets rares comme cet ouvrage qui
datent de 1866 et liquid apprenait
spécialiste des livres c'est une très
très très belles pièces qui nous
particulièrement cher est-ce qu'on a
cherché sur internet on l'a trouvé un
homme à 440 euros
alors on s'est permis de le mettre à 180
euros quand même le but n'est pas de
faire de l'ombre aux autres communautés
mais bien de travailler ensemble pour
vendre un maximum d'objets grâce aux
sites à travers la france c'est plus par
mots clés ou la belle emma us cartable
bougeoirs ce que vous voulez donc voilà
effectivement derrière quand vous
regardez produits vous savez si c'est la
communauté qui à côté de chez vous si
salle au bout de la france donc c'est
délibérément ouvert comme ça pour mon va
dire montrer la richesse des produits
qu'il y a dans les communautés en 48
heures déjà six objets ont trouvé
preneurs les bénéfices sont répartis
entre le site label emmaüs et la
communauté dorment